Gentlemen, we are smokejumpers,...
...the most elite team of firefighters in the world.
We must be at our very best.
Until we can get you back to your parents, I am legally bound to take care of you.
So that's what I'm gonna do.
And in turn, you're going to be obedient so we can do our job.
And when you do this, when you go like that,...
...it's not helpful.
No shenanigans under my watch.
Mean fireman, can't turn my neck.
What needs to happen this second is you gotta watch your tone, little sister.
Or what?
Masher is coming to rock your world.
No!
What just happened?
I think the baby just broke your dog, Supe.
Good doggy.
Guys, I found this cool Nerf guns!
Those aren't Nerf guns!
Whoa, what a rush!
Boom, boom.
Boom, boom?
What's boom boom?
Don't look at me.